it takes commitment and patience to
canvas for votes in the moroccan town of
saleh it's becoming really hard to
convince people just
to trust us as a youth sofian faires is
one of four first-time candidates in
morocco's elections who came of age
during the arab spring more than a
decade ago they believe little has
changed a view it seems shared by the
people they're trying to persuade to
vote they don't believe in the elections
itself and all these three other of the
elections they are like tired of it they
are all times like see the same people
the same people getting elected old
people corrupted like some like
symbolized the corruption in sally
more than half of people in morocco
believe corruption has got worse in the
last 12 months according to transparency
international but critics say it's hard
to tackle when there's no accountability
at the top
we continue to live in an exceptional
despotism
for example we say that it is essential
to discuss the budget of the royal
palace we are against the budget we
can't talk about
we say that the king should not be at
the center of political life because
those that are should be accountable to
the public
king mohammed vi appoints the government
and those who don't toe the line don't
get very far
rasheed auras from morocco's institute
for policy analysis believes many people
in morocco have watched closely what's
happened in neighbouring countries since
the arab spring
there is a majority of young voters who
won't vote because they're not convinced
by the way the game is played now but
don't forget that if one day we do
manage to master the game we manage to
control the elites and the street
perhaps they'll be convinced that we
should go back to a much stronger
autocracy
these young politicians believe there is
appetite for change despite the risks
we must have another referendum for a
new constitution because in our current
one there are many political and
constitutional imbalances if we get a
majority in parliament we apply strong
pressure for real constitutional reforms
the system designed to stop any party
getting a majority such radical policies
are unlikely to get very far
getting into government in morocco is
all about building coalitions and
keeping the palace on side which is why
sometimes it's difficult to find any
major policy differences between the
parties more than 10 years after the
arab spring many here are disappointed
that there aren't real genuine electoral
choices
bernard smith al jazeera rebound